ein bild eine botschaft bundesweit
fordern gastronomen eine exit-strategie
vor einem erdrutsch an lockerungen waren
das robert koch institut eine idee viel
kritik us-präsident trump schlägt vor
corona patienten mit licht und
desinfektionsmittel zu behandeln ein
minister ein versprechen somit schreibt
die rente ist sicher
nordlünen lange zeit arbeits und
sozialminister stirbt im alter von 84
jahren
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend willkommen bei
den heute -nachrichten am freitag
seit wochen leben wir schon mit
angezogener handbremse
die große mehrheit hat sich hierzulande
weitgehend klaglos mit den
einschränkungen abgefunden doch jetzt
wird zunehmend auch darüber diskutiert
wie hoch die kosten werden vor allem aus
der wirtschaft drängen viele massiv auf
mehr freiraum
während die wissenschaftler des
robert-koch-instituts davor warnen das
erreichte zu gefährden
die neuen zahlen insgesamt gibt es laut
johns hopkins universität stand 18 uhr
mehr als 100 53.000 durch tests
bestätigte infektionen in deutschland
mehr als 100 6000 der betroffenen gelten
als genesen 5577 menschen sind in
verbindung mit dem corona virus
gestorben und noch etwas interessantes
die mobilität in deutschland nimmt
wieder zu so mobilfunkdaten die das
robert-koch-institut ausgewertet hat das
zeigt die kurve die ende märz deutlich
nach oben geht
viele sind offenbar wieder mehr
unterwegs über eine komplizierte coroner
lage in deutschland volker wutschik
lehre restaurant stühle bedeuten leere
kassen nicht nur am frankfurter
römerberg gastronomen im ganzen land
haben heute auf ihre existenz sorgen
aufmerksam gemacht sie fordern größere
zuschüssen wollen so schnell wie möglich
wieder öffnen
der rückgang der neuinfektionen macht
vielen bürgern mut lockerungen zu
fordern
deutschlands oberste gesundheits wächter
halten diese einschätzung für gefährlich
wir dürfen jetzt nicht nachlässig werden
gerade im hinblick auf die ersten
lockerung dürfen wie diese dürfen jetzt
nicht zu einem erdrutsch an weiteren
lockerungen führen die wieder nach sich
ziehen
das robert-koch-institut befürwortet
inzwischen die mundschutz pflicht in der
öffentlichkeit ab kommender woche gilt
sie in allen bundesländern die länder
über treffen sich inzwischen bei den
strafandrohung nach dem neuen
bayerischen bußgeldkatalog sollen
ladenbesitzer bis zu 5000 euro zahlen
wenn ihre mitarbeiter keinen mundschutz
tragen
das robert koch institut setzt weiter
auf die umstrittene corona warb sie
identifizierte im fall der fälle die
kontakte eines erkrankten so ließe sich
die infektionskette schnell unterbrechen
auch der chaos computer club warnt
inzwischen vor der geplanten zentralen
speicherung der
bundesgesundheitsminister will nicht
alle daten bedenken gelten lassen viele
handy benutzer geben sonst viele daten
freiwillig preis dieser grund glaube
daran dass daten die bei apple und
google aufgehoben sind
bei amerikanischen grosskonzern besser
geschützt sind als daten die in
deutschland auf servern auch
verstaatlicht kontrolliert liegen die
debatte finde ich müssen wir halt auch
mal führen diesen glauben verstehe ich
manchmal nicht beim gottesdienstbesuch
wird deutschland wieder zum
flickenteppich ein bundesweites konzept
soll zwar her aber heute beschlossen
auch bayern und brandenburg ab anfang
mai wieder mehr gläubige in die kirchen
zu lassen
und wir haben wieder ein politbarometer
zur corona krise und matthias fornoff im
studio dazu hallo martina das ist ja
nicht das erste politbarometer mit der
frage was die bevölkerung vom umgang der
regierung mit dem virus hält bisher
stand eine satte mehrheit hinter ihr ist
das immer noch so ja das ist immer noch
so 90 prozent sagen die regierung macht
ihre arbeit gut dass es erste
lockerungen gibt begrüßt die mehrheit
der deutschen die bestehenden verbote
finden aber auch viel zustimmung
dass der besuch von gottesdiensten im
großen und ganzen verboten bleibt finden
60 prozent richtig für gut zwei drittel
ist das auch okay das kneipen und
restaurants geschlossen bleiben
großveranstaltungen darf es nicht geben
da sind sich fast alle einig 94 prozent
das alles wird nicht spurlos an uns
vorbei gehen auch nicht an der
wirtschaft denken die meisten fast drei
viertel erwarten jetzt dass es mit der
wirtschaft in deutschland abwärts
im märz glaubte dass nur knapp die
hälfte mal ganz konkret gefragt welcher
partei nutzt das krisen-management denn
am meisten
ja cdu und csu die legen zum dritten mal
hintereinander deutlich zu im
politbarometer
die spd profitiert nicht vom krisen
management
wenn am sonntag bundestagswahl wäre käme
die union auf 39 prozent plus 4
die spd auf 16 prozent - 1 af dem 9
prozent minus 1 fdp 5 linke 7 beide
unverändert
die grünen verlieren erneut zwei punkte
und stehen jetzt bei 18 prozent
die korona krise also hat die politische
landschaft doch deutlich verändert kann
man wohl sagen vielen dank matthias das
ganze komplett politbarometer gibt es
eben heute journal um 22 uhr 10
oder natürlich jederzeit online in der
zdf- heute- app mit vielen grafiken und
allen details zum nachlesen
es ist eine überraschung für
grundschulen lehrer und eltern in hessen
eigentlich sollten am montag alle
viertklässler wieder in die schule gehen
bis eine entscheidung des
verwaltungsgerichtshofs heute mittag
dazwischen kam
die viertklässler würden benachteiligt
so die richter weil ihnen ein höheres
chor ohne risiko zugemutet werde als
schülern aus anderen klassenstufen die
erst später in die schule müssten
peter theißen berichtet martin hatte
sich gefreut am montag endlich wieder in
die schule zu gehen
doch nun fehlanzeige und ich finde es
einfach schade eigentlich sollten alle
viertklässler in hessen ab montag wieder
die schulbank drücken
doch die richter am hessischen
verwaltungsgerichtshof sahen hierin den
gleichheitsgrundsatz verletzt diese
schüler der vierten jahrgangsstufen
müssen sich nämlich jetzt rein nach der
verordnung einem höheren
infektionsrisiko aussetzten
als die übrigen schüler ohne dass
hierfür ein sachlicher grund gegeben ist
das ist für alle eltern und schüler die
betroffen sind ist das eine riesen
katastrophe die haben jetzt schon eine
lange zeit hinter sich betreuung ist
eine frage wie mache ich gehe ich mit
meinem arbeitgeber um die berufstätigen
eltern von marten müssen sich nun
jedenfalls weiter abwechseln mit home
office und homeschooling die mir auch
gesagt hat was für vorkehrungen in der
schule getroffen wurden um das alles
nächste woche vernünftig auf die beine
zu stellen und dafür tut es mir einfach
auch leid es war eine bundesweite
entscheidung den unterricht der
viertklässler vorzuziehen um sie besser
auf die weiterführenden schulen
vorzubereiten was passiert nun nach dem
verbot in hessen mögliche rückwirkungen
auf die anderen länder das muss man
sehen
die dortigen oberverwaltungsgerichte
sind natürlich unabhängig die können das
genauso sehen wir unsere
verwaltungsgerichtshof die können das
auch anders sehen zumindest in hessen
bleibt es nun also eine geduldsprobe für
marten und alle viertklässler
wirtschaftsforscher malen die aussichten
für die deutsche wirtschaft tiefschwarz
die experten des instituts der
arbeitsagentur rechnen in diesem jahr
mit bis zu drei millionen arbeitslosen
hinzu kämen noch 2,5 millionen
kurzarbeiter sie sprechen von der
schwersten rezession der
nachkriegsgeschichte und der
geschäftsklimaindex des ifo instituts
ist auf einen tiefstwert gestürzt die
stimmung in den chefetagen sei
katastrophal sagen die forscher
der korona lockdown hat die flugbranche
weltweit heftig getroffen viele airlines
kämpfen ums überleben einige mussten
aufgeben
europas größter luft verkehrskonzern
lufthansa rechnet jetzt mit dem abbau
von rund 10.000 jobs 700 von 770
flugzeugen sind zurzeit stillgelegt
viele mitarbeiter in kurzarbeit und die
tochter germanwings wird ganz dicht
gemacht
derzeit gibt es nur einen notflugplan
wie die branche nach der krise wieder
durchstarten will
dominik löschmeister frankfurt berlin
normalerweise eine flugverbindung im
stundentakt doch in corona zeiten gehen
gerade mal 30
unser maschinen noch täglich in die
hauptstadt die meisten an bord tragen
mundschutz denke ich einfach dass man
rücksicht nimmt auf die risikogruppen
also mehr dass sich sozusagen mit der
maske andere schützen kann jetzt primär
um einen eigenschutz 66 fluggäste sind
an bord und hat 80 hätten platz im a 320
im moment bleibt der mittelsitz frei
eine masken pflicht den flieger die groß
befürworten dass das gibt ihnen
sicherheit das gibt uns sicherheit und
wenn das in der gesellschaft akzeptanz
findet dann hat das antwort auf jeden
fall ein platz
genau das fordert auch die branche in
einem 20 punkte papier der flugverkehr
soll wieder normal laufen mit klaren
regeln für passagiere und besatzung
das ist etwa das abstandhalten an den
flughäfen es sind die hygiene und
desinfektionsmaßnahmen und es ist
schließlich auch an bord unserer
flugzeuge die einführung einer maske
flüchten hunderte flugzeuge der
lufthansa stehen am boden konzernchefs
vorrechnet mit dem abbau von 10.000 jobs
in der korona krise es laufen
verhandlungen um milliardenschwere
staatshilfen
ich denke die politik muss helfen weil
als exportnation ohne eigene
fluggesellschaft das ist schlichtweg
nicht vorstellbar und wäre
volkswirtschaftlich wahnsinn
es wird vermutlich noch einige zeit
dauern bis wieder mehr menschen mit dem
flugzeug unterwegs sind auf jeden fall
wird fliegen in der korona pandemie ein
anderes erlebnis sein das vom virus am
schwersten betroffene land sind die usa
mehr als 50.000 corona tote meldete die
johns hopkins universität dort heute da
meldet sich präsident tram trump mit
ungewöhnlichen ideen zu wort und sorgt
für fassungslosigkeit unter medizinern
uv licht hitze und feuchtigkeit seien
gut gegen das virus
und er schlug vor zu prüfen ob man
desinfektionsmittel nicht auch spritzen
könnte um es zu töten
mehr dazu von elmar theveßen diesmal
hatte donald trump eigens
wissenschaftliche daten bestellt die
zeigen wie licht und wärme das corona
virus angreifen allerdings so der
experte des gesundheitsministeriums
heißt das nicht dass der erreger im
sommer verschwindet der präsident hat
trotzdem eine idee licht
vielleicht durch die haut in menschliche
körper hinein zu strahlen
angenommen wir treffen den körper mit
einem gewaltigen ob nun ultravioletten
oder sehr starken licht und sie sagten
dass das zwar noch nicht geprüft wurde
aber dass sie es jetzt testen werde
transposition ische beraterin hört
schweigen zu und dann noch eine idee da
gibt es ja diese desinfektionsmittel die
das virus in einer minute ausscheiden
gibt es eine möglichkeit etwas zu machen
durch eine injektion beinahe wie ein
durch reinigen
das solle man doch mal testen
die reaktionen waren heftig der
katastrophenschutz eines bundesstaats
twittert keine desinfektionsmittel
injizieren machen sie es nicht noch
schlimmer ein reinigungsmittelhersteller
warnt auf keinen fall injizieren oder
einnehmen
wir haben einen präsidenten der in etwa
sagt injiziert euch desinfektionsmittel
das ist einfach nur gefährlich und eine
show der ignoranz bei der ich mich
schämen würde dahinter zu stehen als
tramp vorwochen dieses malaria
medikament als mögliches wundermittel
gegen korona anpries probierte ein
ehepaar das aus der mann starb us
behörden warnen jetzt vor der einnahme
die lügen des präsidenten kosten leben
meinen demonstranten doch während das
briefing im weißen haus läuft legen sie
leichensäcke natürlich ohne echte körper
am trump hotel in washington ab
und gerade hat trump gesagt er habe die
sache mit den injektionen nicht ernst
gemeint das sei orgasmus gewesen den
religiösen glauben in der gemeinschaft
zu pflegen ist nicht einfach in diesen
tagen auch für muslime in deutschland
nicht für die gerade der fastenmonat
ramadan begonnen hat keine gebete in der
moschee keine traditionellen treffen mit
verwandten und freunden keine
pilgerfahrten das virus zwingt zu einem
sehr privaten ramadan dominik müller
rosell berichtet halt vier heute nacht
in düsseldorf bei borat an und seiner
frau sarah gibt es müsli obst und wasser
solange der morgen noch nicht traut der
ramadan eine zeit der entbehrung
zugleich aber eigentlich auch eine
gesellige zeit wenn abends familien
freunde und moscheegemeinden
zusammenkommen
doch das muss nun ausfallen das fehlt
natürlich im ramadan das merken nicht
nur beim fastenbrechen sondern auch bei
den abendlichen gebeten die nur im
ramadan stattfinden
die firma der muezzin ruft zwar fünfmal
am tag zum gebet aber keiner darf kommen
in der kölner ditib-moschee liest ein
imam aus dem koran vor
die passagen werden dann für die
gläubigen ins netz gestellt die müssen
zu hause aus der ferne am gebet
teilnehmen und wir können nur alle
gemeinsam im kollektiv den lieben herrn
dafür anbieten dass wir wieder an die
frühzeit
da anknüpfen können und diese zeit
gemeinsam in kürze auch überstehen
können
demütig sein in der krise und vor allem
gegenüber gott darum fasten muslime im
ramadan und spüren bewusst hunger und
durst auch getan
in düsseldorf dann merke ich eigentlich
auch dass ich eigentlich gar kein so
starkes wesen bin sondern auch ein
menschliches wesen das auch schwäche
verspüren kann
und das bedeutet mir eingestehe mal da
gegenüber meinem schöpfer meine schwäche
zu verspüren
darum geht es kein gemeinschaftliches
beten und fasten brechen
dieses jahr ist der ramadan eine zeit
ganz besonderer entbehrungen jetzt eine
wichtige nachricht für alle die ein
iphone oder ein ipad benutzen
in der software haben experten schwere
sicherheitslücken entdeckt
es geht um die darauf installierte mail
app von apple
kriminelle könnten an die e mails heran
kommen und zehn manipulieren und wann
kurschilgen hat die details wer auf
seinem iphone die mail app von apple
öffnet der kann ein problem bekommen
denn die nutzung der app ist riskant das
bundesamt für sicherheit in der
informationstechnik schlägt alarm
die sicherheitslücke ist gefährlich das
liegt daran weil bei wenn sie ios 13
haben also das aktuelle betriebssystem
von apple
sämtliche e-mails die sie bekommen
gelesen werden können kopiert werden
können verändert werden können oder
gelöscht werden können und gerade für
das thema diebstahl der digitalen
identität ist das ein spannendes ziel
wenn die app angegriffen wird läuft sie
langsamer sonst merkt der nutzer nichts
von der attacke
cyberkriminelle verschicken eine mail
und verschafften sich so zugang zu den
daten in der app die schwachstelle
existiert in allen versionen ab dem
betriebssystem ios sechs das 2012 auf
den markt kam
wer betroffen ist sollte folgendes tun
der rat ist definitiv auch von den
menschen die die sicherheitslücke
gefunden haben die app zu deinstallieren
zu deaktivieren und vor allem auch die
push nachrichten und den automatischen
nachrichten abruf auszuschalten
unklar ist wie groß der schaden bisher
ist apple sagt die sicherheitslücke
stelle keine unmittelbare gefahr für die
nutzer da eine lösung für das problem
von dem mehr als 500 millionen geräte
weltweit betroffen sind soll es mit dem
nächsten software update geben wann das
kommt ist aber unklar
die taten die einem iraker vorgeworfen
werden sind von besonderer grausamkeit
es geht um völkermord an den g 7 er wird
zum ersten mal vor gericht verhandelt
heute begann der prozess gegen das
mutmaßliche mitglied vor dem
oberlandesgericht frankfurt
der 27-jährige soll 2015 im irak eine
jüdische mutter und deren tochter als
sklaven gekauft haben als strafaktion
soll er das kind gefesselt der gluthitze
ausgesetzt haben bis es starb
die rente ist sicher das ist wohl der
berühmteste satz von norbert blüm 1
bundes arbeits und sozialminister jetzt
ist er im alter von 84 jahren in bonn
gestorben
blumen galt ist das soziale gewissen der
union er führte die pflegeversicherung
ein und war der einzige minister der
bundeskanzler kohl die gesamten 16 jahre
seiner regierungszeit im kabinett
begleitet hat ina baltes und daniel
pontzen erinnern
er bleibt zeitlebens politisch die wir
bei einem seiner letzten tv auftritte
ich bin dagegen die alten gegen die
jungen auszuspielen so eine art
generation kommt von 1982 an ist er der
gefühlt ewige arbeitsminister der ära
kohl ein vollblutpolitiker immer
kampfeslustig
kein leichtes verhältnis zu kohl in den
16 jahren wie sie gemeinsam im kabinett
waren später folgte gar der endgültige
bruch sein dialekt verrät die heimat
1935 in rüsselsheim geboren beginnt er
mit 14 eine ausbildung als handwerker
dann abendgymnasium und abitur ist
folgen lange lehr und wanderjahre
lkw-fahrer kenne straßenbau in
griechenland gastarbeiter in
griechenland kunstschmied in der türkei
studierte philosophie 67 doktor phil
blüms position links der mitte oft nicht
nur im cdu maßstab er kämpft für den
sozialstaat führt die pflegeversicherung
ein und steht für das vielleicht
berühmteste versprechen der berti somit
schreiben die rente ist sicher er war
einer von denen die in deutschland dazu
beigetragen haben dass die demokraten
sich trauen dass sie sich vertrauen das
man weiß du musst streit mit den um den
richtigen weg aber du kannst sicher sein
der handelt und reagiert demokratisch
und er hat es in einer ganz
unnachahmlichen art und weise getan mit
viel herz viel verstand viel humor und
deswegen werden wir alle werde ich ihn
vermissen humor spielt auch nach seinem
polit leben eine große rolle unter
anderem macht der kabarett doch die
politik lässt ihn nicht los 2016 reiste
ins flüchtlingscamp nach domini kämpfen
für benachteiligte eine konstante in
seinem leben eine besondere
persönlichkeit und wir haben noch etwas
das es nicht alle tage gibt die rolling
stones haben einen neuen song
veröffentlicht erstmals seit 2012
passend zur corona krise mit dem
düsteren titel living in a ghost town
leben in einer geisterstadt
[Musik]
es geht um einsamkeit und isolation
damit haben jetzt auch rockstars zu
kämpfen zum wetter zwar wird das
wochenende weniger warm aber der
dringend benötigte kräftige regen ist
nach wie vor nicht in sicht
mehr zum wetter gleich von katja hoffe
das war es von uns danke für ihr
interesse
das heute journal mit claus kleber um 22
uhr 10 und uns gibt es morgen wieder
punkt 19 uhr jetzt folgt hier das zdf
spezial corona krise im sport ihnen noch
einen entspannten freitag
[Musik]
meine damen und herren der wind hat sich
gedreht er kommt jetzt aus nord bis
nordwest und zogen heute höre
wolkenfelder hinweg und hier über der
nordsee kommen schon wieder neue wolken
heran und die bringen in der nacht auch
einige regenschauer an der ostsee bei
temperaturen von 11 bis 4 grad und
morgen ziehen diese dichtere wolken hier
langsam weiter richtung südosten an der
nordsee kommt schon wieder schön die
sonne zum vorschein und zwischen der
unteren donau und der mosel strahlt die
sonne morgen auch der dringend
erforderliche regen der beschränkt sich
übermorgen doch wirklich auch die
alpentäler da kannst du vielleicht
meinen kleinen regenschauer geben auch
am sonntag ändert sich an diesem wetter
nichts auch bei den temperaturen wird
sich wenig ändern so bis zum 23 oder 24
grad sind möglich in der neuen woche
gibt dann der dienstag hoffnung auf mehr
regen
schönen abend noch